you know this is why I think stay comes
is wrong right so uh big threat from
stay comes I mentioned I think three
times now and uh no no but I think it's
important that what's interesting about
this is It's a mainstream brand and
they're constantly these brands are
trying to one-up each other Wendy's was
like always snarking and they were more
of like the youthful exuberant like well
you suck yeah man
and people would follow it and laugh
then stay comes comes out and uh the
Wikipedia says that they they receive
accolades for acting like a real person
on Twitter well the interesting thing is
this Twitter thread that staycoms put
out is a Centrist view on societal
collapse and talking about what we need
to do saying that experts need to admit
when they were wrong and apologize for
it and the other side needs to recognize
that they have limitations too and there
are experts who probably know more than
them and I'm like
thank you stacoms for trying yeah but
you are late to the party Joe Biden has
near Universal approval from Democrats
and near Universal disapproval from
Republicans nothing will change this
nothing
nothing you could you could you could
you could go to a Biden supporter and be
like I will give you one million dollars
to put on a Maga hat and they're going
to be like no
okay maybe a million yeah a million
Millions but I'm exaggerating but I
gotta be honest I uh there I I'm willing
to bet that you know a lot of these
people on the left will not do anything
to benefit themselves if it puts them at
odds with their tribe they're scared to
break from it and it's this it's the
social order thing that humans have
where it's like you got to be a part of
a certain tribe otherwise
you'll be at risk yeah but the
interesting thing here is that
conservatives tend to be more
individualistic so they're less
concerned about being outed but still
kind of are like when it comes to the
culture War right there are numerous
instances where you could say something
that will get a bunch of people on the
right angry with you and they'll start
canceling you and they'll do the exact
same thing as the left will do not exact
same I I talk about this a lot where I
think it's it is different like a public
conservative has a much tougher time
getting canceled than a public leftist I
mean they can't you know recently
recently I've been clicking like
hashtags like to see like why a
celebrity was you know trending and it's
because they hate all of them all the
celebrities are like not left enough
like this celebrity used to be
um Lena Dunham uh trended recently they
hate her now she used to be one of them
and now now she's out
um I just don't see that happening in
the same way you're right that's why I
say it's the it's the exception on the
right but the rule on the left yeah so
try there are still tribalists on the
right who will be like you can't you
know I reject this you're wrong you're a
grifter and stuff but on the laugh it's
like geez it's like 99 things you could
say to get fired you know get canceled
and one thing to stay in line and
they're probably on the right with
Republicans and conservatives and the
intellectual dark web kind of centrists
it's 99 things you can say without
anyone caring but that one thing you can
say they'll get you canceled yep yeah
there was a uh Charlie Kirk you know was
talking about Simone biles and all of a
sudden I see that he's trending there's
an uproar
we brought out the other day but I think
this is a really great example Philip
DeFranco did a segment where he used an
image of Charlie Kirk with a shrunken
face for his thumbnail and I'm like why
what Phil you know do you know DeFranco
is no he's one of the first big
YouTubers he does he would do news and
he's like you know he would be like you
just got filled in and that was his bit
and he would like talk about the news
and it was always very like moderate he
actually interviewed I think he
interviewed Gary Johnson during what was
it like 20 was it 26-16 yeah he runs
every time so yeah that's what I voted
for him but he was like you know felt
the time was like libertarian column
raising on rational and now he's like he
was he came out when it came when it
came to the Covington kids he made a
video where he was wrong then when it
came there's other instances but now
it's like Charlie Kirk says something
that people think is stupid and I'm like
who cares whatever like I don't know
Charlie would say whatever he wants it's
got no bearing on the Olympics some guy
in an opinion great and then I
criticized Phil because he tweeted like
you're a you know whatever and was
insulting him but then I saw today he
was like we're back and it's a thumbnail
and not only is he talking about Charlie
Kirk which is fine but he he does his
meme where they shrink Charlie Kirk's
face which I I'll admit great meme it's
really funny like the the joke is that
every time Charlie makes a point his
face shrinks or something memes are
great you know by all means make fun of
him and Ben and everybody else and me
and you know who I don't care but like
why would someone who is known for being
a like straight shooter news personality
all of a sudden be playing tribal
politics and just insulting someone for
Content this is cultural Decay yeah when
you can see it's infecting everything
the New York Times has become this our
mainstream news apparatus has completely
become crap all over people and find
whatever reason to hate somebody for
tribal points and then even now I mean
YouTube is built on this basically drama
channels and here you go this is it our
entire news media is now just who can I
crap on for clicks yeah strife cells I
mean that's like it's popular I I I find
myself like sometimes clicking on a
headline of like two celebrities I've
never even heard of to be like this
celebrity and this celebrity are like
beefing and like oh what are they
fighting about like what happened like I
don't even know them I don't even know
who they are I'll do that and then I'll
like I'll I'll see it
I'll X out really fast I hope the
algorithm didn't catch that but it did
of course yeah it knows I clicked I I
apparently you know people were
commenting the other day that some
leftist Channel like made a video about
be like an Expose and I'm like do this
like the 80th expose who cares I just
ignore all this stuff and then there's
like you know people messaging me right
now because there's another hit piece
coming it's a big one I guess and I'm
like I literally don't care like I just
I'm not gonna make videos about this
stuff I don't I don't care about myself
enough to engage in in you know
interpersonal conflict on YouTube or to
be like you know oh Charlie Kirk said
this now like AOC she's in congress with
12 million or whatever followers and
she's extremely prominent and
influential she's a politician CEOs
politicians and to an extent many
personalities I think it's it's it's
fair game but when it's like
people just doing drama to bicker with
each other news outlets being like we're
gonna write garbage fake trash to like
try and get somebody I'm like
you know what there's a rock I can crawl
under and just you know dig a hole and
play video games the rest of my life
that was interesting I said how that you
could get a Biden supporter put on a
Maga hat if you paid him a million bucks
that you couldn't but but you're kind of
right that if you bribe people they will
change their political ideology and the
problem is Biden has his finger on the
money printer so he's bribing everyone
right now
are they unloading you know to I I don't
think
uh maybe a million dollars would get a a
Biden voter to put on a Maga 50. you
could probably get tons of Biden
supporters to put on my house for 50
bucks they don't have loyalty to that
guy no no it's but they they they are
scared of looking like Republicans maybe
yeah you put that picture circulates
lose everything they think it's a clan
hat like they'll they'll be like no way
dude yeah it's like tell them this put
the Hat on take a picture of it and I'll
give you fifty thousand dollars they
probably say no and I'm not kidding
maybe that's a good idea for a man in
the street you know video we'll go to
we'll go to New York and back how do you
feel about Trump 50's still too much I
think you have to go for 50 bucks like
50 bucks is sort of like it's a one
second thing like I just see how little
people really care yeah yeah 50 000 I
mean you know I put on like I can't even
know what I put on yeah I put on two
masks but I mean like obviously there's
regular people who voted who don't
really care all that much but I mean
like look at look at what David Hogg
said about wearing masks where he's like
I'm Gonna Keep wearing because I don't
want people to think I'm a republican
it's like why what I live in like the
super left this area where I mean masks
were absolutely like you know a signal
that I belong I'm part of this group if
you're not wearing one you're not part
of the group and it's important to
people to be part of the group so you
know yeah maybe fifty thousand dollars a
lot of money it's too much it's too much
you gotta like do like 100 bucks like
this here's a hundred dollars like put
on this hat no they I think you could
get it yeah really well they'd put it on
maybe like yeah on camera we're filming
right yeah I think I think the 100 bucks
would do it wow I mean people people are
about to get the shots they like
deferred for like so long like the shot
you know the vaccines have been out for
like months and months but now they're
gonna get it for the hundred bucks but
what I mean is like when you look at
those poll who are Democrats yeah and
they're 90 approval for Joe Biden those
are the kind of people I think would be
like never right regular people on the
street right on the street would do it
yeah of course of course of course I
mean like the partisans yeah my
neighborhood will be tough Park Slope
would be
I'll give you I'll give you a hundred
dollars to wear the Maga hat and we're
gonna film you I got a feeling they're
gonna say no yeah no it would have to be
like regular people on the street how
about a college campus
it's really easy because they want the
money boy would they get in trouble if
that photo goes around what are they
gonna say they paid me to wear it
they'll be like what you took money to
wear that thing
what you're Nazi I do think I I do think
Money Talks yeah I'm willing to bet that
you could find like a moderate left or
right personality offer enough money and
they'll flip side since they'll wait
it's the whole you know you offer enough
money and people will do it but I think
for 50 50 000 everybody does it like
yeah yeah um 10 000 everybody does I
think so no I don't know about I don't
know about everybody I think everybody a
photo of you wearing that hat you will
never get hired in your city your your
friends will be like what is this and
you'll try claiming it but 50k but they
paid me to do it yeah they paid me a lot
of money to do it they'll be like you
took money to support Donald Trump how
dare you I mean look you see what some
people get canceled for I'm not
convinced
people on the street would do a lot for
a Klondike bar you know what I mean so
sure yeah you should just offer just the
Klondike Bar
we got money I want to do this yeah I
want to I want to go out on the street
and I want to go to you know what would
be funny we're in an area that's very
trumpy I'll go in there and ask people
to wear a Biden hat like how much for
you to wear this bike now take a picture
of you you know you know what happened
every single conservative would be like
how much money yeah whatever right you
know why I don't care multi Klondike Bar
well no it's like you find a guy with a
Maga hat and you say bro I got 50 bucks
for you to wear this Biden hat it'll be
like yeah put it on and be like are we
good all right thanks have a nice day
because they don't care no one's gonna
come after them for wearing a Biden hat
right yep Trump had on the other hand
right because you know there's
acceptable opinions and there's
unacceptable opinions it would be
hilarious when like the Trump supporter
is like his friend walks up and he's
like I just saw a picture of you and
abide man and he's gonna be like they
gave me 50 bucks let's go get some beers
no one will care no no okay in fact uh
interestingly there's a phenomenon where
Urban centers even in red states are
very pro-democrat and very critical race
Theory and all this stuff that's the
craziest thing to me yeah it is really
crazy like to hear that about that in
like Tulsa and another place yeah yeah
even in West Virginia you'll we'll drive
through some areas and we'll see like
the the new Pride flags and stuff like
that and I'm like
West Virginia huh but not everybody you
still if you go to urban areas you tend
to see it but West Virginia is like the
second most Trump supporting State yeah
so they are all you got crazy things to
say about a lot of crazy things I
believe it yeah I'm sometimes like I
would not want to have a conversation
you know but there are a lot of where we
are there's a lot of Rich Democrat
people from DC who move out here because
Freedom right people like the freedom
that's what happens nobody wants to live
in DC there's mask mandates right nobody
wants to live in Maryland they're very
restrictive and for a while restrictions
as well now they can drive about an hour
and a half be in West Virginia
there's a funny thing because uh in the
area where I actually lived they say
that they can all tell who the DC
transplants are because they'll be like
someone left their garbage at raccoons
came and they'll be like and yeah
they're like welcome to the mountain and
they're like there was a bear the other
day and they're like oh how many just
one
then there's like gunshots going off and
then people are posting online like why
are there gunshots and they'll complain
they'll come out and be like you know
I'm wondering why it's happening and
they're like people shoot all the time
yeah there's like a range right down the
map like right down the road what do you
expect there it's crazy there are people
who live within like a few minutes of
walking there's like an open range in
the mountain and there's like a house
right there there's a bunch of houses
and you just like walk for about 10
minutes and then you're at a shooting
range and the people just live right
there shooting every day non-stop and
there's hunting
yeah yeah so these these these uh Urban
liberals you don't want to stay away man
because it's a bunch of gun right now
with guns and bears yes and bears
records we really need to spread out
it's so important I I kept thinking when
I was like a kid like 10 12 years ago oh
we'll just build magnetic trains from
small village to small village and re
renegotiate our our infrastructure we'll
have instead of big cities we'll have
lots of little ones all interconnected
where's the magnetic trains guys what
what about like cities that are
concentric circles run by super
computers all right that sounds like
burning man
minus the computer I guess yeah we we
um
we don't we don't uh uh have a
collective Cultural Mission it's so
weird I I maybe because our technology
has been suppressed for so long by like
the electric grid they want to keep
those copper wires pumping electricity
and making their money off of their
copper pipes and we have no competition
bro that's the problem the copper
industry we went to the moon because we
were like Russia what up yeah Soviet
Union we're gonna go to the moon so the
U.S had been losing every element of the
Space Race Sputnik launched first they
put a dog in space and the US was like
every step of the way we're behind let's
go big yeah and so I think like the only
thing the U.S actually won was getting
to the Moon because they were like well
we can't win all of these things let's
just so they rallied everybody they made
it the mission everybody was cheering
they were like yeah and at the same time
there was still a bunch of crazy stuff
going on outside of that you know I
apologize
um Trump was giving a speech and he said
that we'll be the first country to put a
man on Mars and I didn't believe him it
was like it just I just heard it and I
was like you blow heart like you know
prove it prove it I don't believe you
anymore I I'm and I know that the
corporations are more effective at
getting people into space than the
American government if you look at the
last year of activity
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time